[MUSIC]
My earliest childhood memories
was playing with Legos.
I loved building Lego cities,
with chips for the pirates, and
hospitals for the doctors, and
trucks for the firefighters.
It was my world of endless possibilities
and I was the architect of my own dreams.
I can also remember that whenever
I finished building a city,
I would always have one
piece left over and
it was always the same piece.
It was always the woman.
Only the woman does not have a uniform,
she did not have a function.
She did not have a role.
She was not a chef.
She was not a builder.
She was simply a woman.
So I didn't know what to do with her and
I look around my city try to see
where she fit, maybe sicker inside
a house and hope no one would notice.
Why was the woman the only
character that looked
like me an afterthought in my own dream?
I can trace back to this memory my
decision to become an entrepreneur and
a designer,
because I wanted to play by my own rules.
And design gave me the skills and
the tools to build a world of my own.
And as a designer, I know that the world
around us is shaped like design choices.
So for that simple reason,
if we have designed woman out,
we can design woman in.
How?
The first step to jumpstart this
change is to realize that the world
around us is the result of what
researchers call the generic masculine.
The generic masculine means that we,
you and I,
we interpret everything as male
unless specified as female.
It means that when we say human,
we mean man.
And by making men our
normal standard human,
we erase woman from the picture.
And her absences are everywhere.
They are in the history rewrite,
in the policy we pursue,
in the cities we plan, and the algorithms
we code and in the products we design.
Her absences can take the shape
of an unthreatening toy,
but they can also be deadly.
Women are 17% more likely to
die in a car crash then men
according to the US Department
of Transportation.
Why?
Because cars are designed for
men's bodies.
Car crash test dummies are designed
after men's measurements.
And car seat belts are designed for men's
torsos, so they simply do not account for
breast tissue or pregnancy.
There are more fetal deaths
from car crashes than
any other trauma, and
I ask, why is it this way?
The leading cause of death of women
in the USA is cardiovascular disease,
yet only 25% of hospital emergency
treatments are given to women, why?
Because diagnosis criteria were
designed to fit men's symptoms.
And unfortunately a woman's heart
attack looks nothing like a man's.
Instead of experiencing chest and
arm pain,
women often experience breathlessness,
stomach pain, nausea, and fatigue.
Her symptoms are referred to as atypical.
Let that word sink in, atypical.
So instead of receiving
the treatment that she needs and
deserves, she is sent home
with a prescription for
anxiety, why is it this way?
And even when bias design does not
kill women, it makes their life so
much harder, unsafe and tiring.
When we take men's perceptions,
patterns, and
behaviors and make them our golden rule,
when we assume that what he wants,
does and needs,
represents us all,
then our design is flawed from the get go.
And once you see it, you cannot unsee
it because it is everywhere around us.
And since we stand on the Stanford campus,
let's glance at our surroundings.
I see a university campus with
outdoor lighting so dim and
dispersed that female students who
live here feel unsafe at night and
think twice before choosing their paths.
Why didn't Stanford make
their walkways brighter?
Because lighting was not
designed with woman in mind.
The very lengthy and very detailed
Stanford lighting guidelines make it
clear light is meant to orient travelers
and to unify campus architecture.
And places no emphasis on safety or
security perceptions that are central for
their female community.
I can also see a full time executive
program that is only 25% female.
Why can't Stanford get more executive
woman to apply and come once admitted?
What invisible hurdles are still there?
Since this program targets men and women
over 30, I'd recommend we take a long,
hard look at childcare services
provided because half of the men
in our program are fathers, and
only three women are mothers.
How do the systems in
place fail to account for
the unique challenges faced by mothers
that fathers surpass mothers seven to one?
Why is it this way?
I believe we're in the right place and
in the right time to redesign
a world that also works for women.
Because we are no longer the children
playing with the Lego sets we were given.
I invite you all,
to reframe the way that you think of your
role from decision makers in business,
in education,
and in policy, and
to think of yourself as designer.
To everyone listening, hear this.
You are a designer.
Because whenever you're making a decision
about what business model to build,
what policy to pursue, or what strategy to
roll out, you are making design choices.
So, dear designers know
that you are powerful.
Use your power to advocate for
your user and their needs.
All of your users and all of their
needs because they are not in the room
when you're making a decision about them,
so be their voice.
This responsibility lies on all of us,
not just on woman and
it influences all products,
all services, and all policies.
And I asked you to go beyond the business
school questions, why this and why now?
And ask the most important
design question.
Why is it this way?
Leaders of today and leaders of tomorrow,
how will you design a world
that also works for women?
[MUSIC]